le virus chinois c'est la formule
employée par donald trump chaque jour
pour désigner la pandémie qui touche le
monde entier
le président américain se dit contrarié
par le supposé manque de coopération de
pékin et multiplie ces accusations pour
faire porter la responsabilité du virus
sur le gouvernement chinois cela ce
serait beaucoup mieux passé si on avait
su tout cela quelques mois plus tôt cela
aurait pu être contenue dans la région
de chine
d'où le virus est parti le monde paie le
prix fort pour ce qu'ils ont fait et le
monde paye le prix fort pour ne pas
avoir divulgué l'information
tout le monde le sait pour ce qui est de
croire ce qu'ils disent maintenant
j'espère que c'est vrai qui sait mais
j'espère que c'est vrai des accusations
qui irrite les autorités chinoises pékin
exhorté états unis de cesser de
politiser l'épidémie et de stigmatiser
la chine depuis le premier jour où les
états unis ont provoqué l'incident
la chine a dit aux états unis qu'elle se
réservait le droit de réagir et de
prendre des mesures si les états unis
agissent et seul il en subirait de
graves conséquences
ce qui est regrettable c'est que les
états unis du début jusqu'à la fin et
fait la sourde oreille et ignorer les
négociations répéter les allocutions
solennelles de la chine allant de plus
en plus loin dans la mauvaise direction
en attendant aux etats unis les banques
d'ims explose les vendeurs font état
d'une nouvelle clientèle
la communauté asiatique qui craindraient
les répercussions raciste en lien avec
le cours aux navires us